desesperación miedo y caos ciudadanos
afganos intentan huir de su país tras la
toma de kabul
y las fuerzas estadounidenses lanzan
disparos al aire para proteger a sus
diplomáticos y evitar que los civiles se
metan a la pista de aterrizaje del
aeropuerto de la capital donde ya se
registran víctimas mortales la guerra no
sólo afecta a nivel individual sino
también a todo el país y a todos los que
viven en él lo peor es que esto afecta a
la siguiente generación del país
lamentablemente nuestra generación no
puede garantizar el camino para su
educación mientras tanto sigue la
evacuación de diplomáticos del país
asiático un grupo de 70 países de todos
los continentes piden a quienes ocupan
cargos de autoridad en afganistán que
dejen marchar a los extranjeros
emiratos árabes unidos- alemania
finlandia japón australia nueva zelanda
entre otros pusieron en acción su plan
de salida este lunes
desde el comienzo hasta ahora no hubo
deseo de un afganistán pacífico no hubo
una estrategia ni hoja de ruta para un
afganistán pacífico quieren más poder a
nivel regional
las críticas arrecian tanto dentro como
fuera de eeuu contra el gobierno del
presidente de byd en por la caótica
retirada de las tropas del territorio
afgano